so i'm going to basically talk about
if we take ioe as connected intelligence
and intelligence is the stuff that mark
talked about the processing the data the
security i'm going to most focus mostly
on the connected part how do you provide
connectivity to this many nodes and the
first question i'm going to talk about
is something that
tom already touched upon and that's the
applications
so we know we know the usual suspects of
applications in iot we have you know
healthcare applications we have home
automation industrial applications
automotive but what i wanted to add here
is perhaps the most exciting of
applications the ones that are most
relevant we still don't know
precisely because we don't know the
capabilities of the technology and the
assumptions we make the assumptions and
the applications we think about today
are based on the capabilities we have
today and we know technology evolves we
know that as technology evolves the way
we use technology evolves and sometimes
that evolution is very drastic
significant you know the capabilities we
have
change over time and the way we use
technology changes now have we seen
these other places yes
think about cell phones
1970s
the most important application of cell
phones was talking on the phone it was a
very important thing you can talk on the
go
but today i don't know about you but i
don't really talk on my phone now if my
wife and friends were here they would
say well you never pick it up but no
that's not true i would defend myself
saying that it's because i use it for
for email for text for other
applications but sometimes i use it for
applications that you could never think
about back then navigation when i go to
a new place i turn my phone on and that
kind of gives me confidence i know where
i am i'm going left and right there's
uber there's where i'm going around so i
think that part of those new
applications we can never predict
because we don't know all the
capabilities of the technology as we are
at this stage now we can go even further
electricity the killer app back then was
well you have a light bulb you can turn
it on and lighting is huge right and i
can imagine today you use electricity
for more interesting ways also
but even if you take today's technology
if you assume that we're going on a
trajectory that's predicted by today's
technology
we see that internet of things is
growing at an exponential rate
and the growth factor is higher than the
other
technology tablets and smartphones and
pcs
and so we're getting into the trillion
domain that actually tom mentioned so
we're going to tens of billions hundreds
of billions and now in trillions of
connected devices
so that's the question i wanna i i wanna
ask is
if we assume that we're going to
trillion connected devices how do we
provide connectivity assuming that we
have good applications for that how do
you provide wireless connectivity for a
trillion things and to see the problem
in that let's take a look at the regular
radio
so if you open up a radio do some
surgery on the radio you'll see that you
have some usual suspects in there you
have the microchip with the packaging
you have some antennas
you have a reference crystal you have
some external components some pcb board
you have some batteries on the egg on
the reverse side
and
my
basically point is this kind of
technology is not going to scale into
the trillion numbers
just because of think about the
batteries think about the cost and the
size and the scalability of the
technology we have today so if you're
thinking about a thousand radius per
person this bluetooth low energy stuff
is not going to get us there this is my
opinion you may disagree
and and the reason for that are three
things cost is too expensive
so 10
trillion of these 10 trillion dollars
we would need a little bit more of
banknotes from other places footprint
is another issue a lot of these things
you want to put them around you don't
want to have a credit card size radio
around you and the third one is
scalability a thousand radius per person
means at any moment in time i want to
talk to a thousand things today's radio
are not designed to do that so
what we really need is orders of
magnitude improvement in all these three
fronts we can't just say well i have 10
20 improvement here i'll do some
tweaking and optimization
you know i'll do some aggregation now it
has to be orders of magnitude if we're
getting to the trillion numbers so let's
see
how we can get there now one key
observation you can make is today's
radio the way you design wireless
devices today is very symmetrical so the
sensor and my cell phone kind of have
the same technology
in terms of complexity it's very
symmetrical but if we move to this
trillion number it doesn't have to be
symmetrical i'm talking to a thousand
radials so i can move all the complexity
from that sensor all the way back to the
main radio and that gives me at least
one degree of freedom to get other
magnitude improvements so that's one key
observation in our design now in the
next few slides i'm going to pick one of
the topics one of the issues and i'm
going to the at the risk of
oversimplifying i'm going to spend a few
slides describing the challenge and how
we overcame
that challenge
so
i know tom mentioned tesla so we the
first problem we want to eliminate the
battery so eliminating the battery is
one key issue we know we can't have a
thousand batteries tom mentioned this
already we have a thousand batteries
running thousand devices running in a
year each
so on average every day i have to change
three batteries at home so that really
doesn't make too much sense at least to
me
so wireless power delay has been there
people have been playing with this for a
long time now granted tesla had much
more cooler toys to play with than i'm
allowed here and safety probably wasn't
the number one concern back then
but he still had the main i mean the
problem is still open today the
challenge is
how do you deliver wireless power to
something that's very small and that
poses extremely difficult engineering
challenge something that's extremely
small at the distance at a reasonable
distance so what we really want is a
distance to size ratio to be large so if
something is a millimeter size and i
want to communicate at the meter i want
the distance to size to be a factor of a
thousand or ten thousand so that's an is
a very challenging problem
and i'm going to spend a couple of
slides figuring telling you why this is
a challenging problem now conventional
wisdom when we try to do wireless power
delivery
we use our frequencies in which you know
our cell phones operate one to two
gigahertz the wavelength is about 30
centimeters
and the device you want to power up is a
millimeter now the wavelength is much
larger than the device
so what's the problem with that the
problem is you have on the transmitter
you can't focus the beam into the
receiver that becomes much more
inefficient on the transmitter side
and on the receiver you can't pick up
the power the power coupling to that
electromagnetic wave is much more
inefficient so what happens is you
basically have a double hit here and you
can't power up effectively
so what you really need to do is make
sure these two are matched the
wavelength and the size of the aperture
are matched and you can see this in a
different way if i forgive me for a
couple of equations here so if you start
and write the received power
in frieza's equation at a given distance
d
all you need from this equation is the
wavelength ends up on the top here so
lower frequencies are better and that's
conventional wisdom like low frequencies
travel further out but the problem with
this equation is it assumes a fixed
antenna gain
whereas in the iot domain we have a
fixed radius size i want to be a
millimeter size so we have to rewrite
the equation and when we rewrite based
on a fixed aperture you'll see that the
wavelength ends up down there and now
higher frequencies are better up to a
point that they get matched to the
aperture
now what are the limitations on the
other side the limitation is that the
power recovery efficiency circuit
microchip efficiency goes down with
frequency so there's usually an optimal
frequency that you have to find based on
size and various different parameters so
once you have that then you can actually
go
and have a more efficient power-up
scheme
we can go into more details take into
account losses in the link i don't want
to go into the details of these
equations but the end story is
with a given size a millimeter size the
power that you receive goes up
up to a point that it saturates is where
you get match to the aperture of the
receiver so
it again it goes against the
conventional wisdom because we're using
very high frequencies into 20 30
gigahertz to power up these tiny devices
so what we're proposing
is you have this gateway device as tom
mentioned so you have this cell phone
and so this cell phone communicates with
all these iot devices it could be a cell
phone or tablet and these incoming
messages
that are in millimeter wave
act as the downlink data as well as the
power link so not only you send the
messages but you also power up the
devices using the same scheme
and once you power them up they
communicate back using another frequency
in the millimeter wave so that's the
architecture we're thinking about and
designing right now
so this was of course a crazy idea if
you go to a circuit design and say not
only i want something that has no
batteries but i also want this tiny
little thing and i want it to operate in
millimeter waves they're going to come
back and say you're crazy
so we had to go and actually build this
so we built the whole chip and you see
here
this is the entire radio on a us penny
compared to mr lincoln here and we're
about twice the size of his nose i mean
if you compare the dimension to this
radio and and so this radio itself has
if we zoom into the chip it weighs about
the milligram and it contains
all the elements you see in a regular
radio
this is true single chip solutions if
there are any chip designers out there
one thing you notice about this chip is
there are no pads
there are no electrical pads with this
everything is wireless in and out so
when you want to measure this it's very
easy we don't have some of the problems
that mark mentioned you're just going to
the lab and wirelessly measure it
there's no landing and connection and
all of that so we solved that problem
too yeah
i can't mention that on live tv
so
the the the other problem is
you know so it includes everything and
it has wireless now one thing i didn't
talk about this energy is one point but
there's no timing in this clock right
every radio has a crystal reference that
keeps the time we don't have that here
so how do you design a radio with that
so we have to overcome a couple more
problems a few years of work
condensed in one slide
it achieves 12 megabits per second on
aggregate uplink and the standby power
consumption is a one and a half
microwatts and this is orders of
magnitude as i said lower than your
regular radio and in terms of cost this
would cost in the order of sense in the
large volume scale especially the
testing would be easier
large-scale testing would be easier
because it's wireless
so here i have a video of this thing in
action so what we did is we got these
got these radios
and we used double-sided tape nothing
fancy double-sided tape and we stuck him
on top of a substrate so you see these
radios on top of the substrate and the
red trace is going to show the incoming
messages to the radio and the black
trace here is going to show the up link
from the radio the messages that the
radio sends back
so let's see if the video loads up here
here we go
so as you bring it into range
you'll see that this this is the
messages the ultra wideband messages
that are coming back here i don't know
if you see it from the back
and then we also test it from the back
side so if you look at the back side
you'll see that you know again i get the
messages in and i respond with the
encrypt with the coded data we're doing
a ppm coding on on the return so
you know with this technology now you
can think about applications in which
you can have trillions of devices for
one application very short term
applications we were thinking about is
if you have a temperature sensor on this
and you put it on a band-aid now you
have a whole device that costs a few
cents and everyone everywhere that goes
to a medical facility whether the
hospital or a clinic will have one of
these band-aids costs a few cents they
can monitor their temperature wirelessly
so you can put a lot of this radio on a
lot of different um applications and and
because of the cost and size um you have
a lot more flexibility
so let me go to a different topic now
i'm going to spend a couple of slides on
um another technology we've been working
on the past few years and and the
question we asked ourselves here is can
we take this one step further can we
make it smaller going to the dimensions
of a human hair
and
embed them in the human body as
implantable devices now one thing you
might ask is why the hell would i want
one of these in my body well there are
some applications believe it or not for
the classical ones are the pacemaker
but there are applications where you
implant them in the brain
for modulating neural activity
you can think about applications where
you actually implant this close to an
organ to monitor and modulate local
physiology
you can think of them extremely going
into the bloodstream measuring
biomarkers in the extreme sense or a
digestible pill that we just saw in the
previous slides that actually goes in
and then communicates so the key
challenge here is although we want all
of this um
implantable devices we also want to
these to be extremely small but keep the
functionality we don't want them to be
small and
dumb we want them to keep the essential
functionality of a radio on a sensor but
at the same time the dimensions need to
be small
now the problems are kind of the same
except for so you need to match the
wavelength to the aperture
except for two things now we want them
to be smaller so we're going to less
than a millimeter size and the second
problem is the human body is a big
obstacle
and it's not easy to power up in
something inside the human body so
that's two problems we have
so the usual trick we played on the
other
technology we can't play here if we up
the frequency to reduce the wavelength
the absorption increases so think of a
microwave oven right 2.4 gigahertz a lot
of that energy translates to heat
not in going into the device
so the question we asked was
do we know of any other waves that are
safe in the human body
and at the same time the wavelength is
much smaller
and the answer to that is yes we know
sound waves same technology used for
ultrasound imaging
the speed of sound is five volts of
magnitude smaller than the speed of
light so that if therefore the
wavelength is much smaller so now i can
effectively power up these implantable
devices at extremely small dimensions
and at the same time the transmitter can
also focus the energy because of the
small wavelength into the receiver so
that's the technology we've been
thinking about
and just to show that this is not just
fully tolerated pipe dream
we actually went ahead and designed the
system with a bunch of transceivers so
this would be very similar to your
ultrasound imager
it will send messages to these
implantable devices and also communicate
back
and we built the first generation this
is a
project in collaboration with professor
kuriyakuba at the ee department so the
first generation we have the proof of
concept device which has a piezoelectric
device
harvests the ultrasound energy
translates it into electrical energy and
then the chip takes that energy
communicates on downlink and
communicates back so we have
bi-directional communication with these
embedded devices and as you can see the
second generation we're already pushing
the dimension of these things further
down again on a u.s penny now we've
graduated from mr lincoln's nose to mrs
lincoln's eyes i think here
making it even even smaller so we're
pushing down to about a couple hundred
microns uh dimension so what i wanted to
conclude with is first of all the most
interesting applications that we can
think about the most exciting of
applications are yet to come
so we still have a lot more exciting
technology to work with and as we have
more
evolving technology we'll have better
more exciting applications and secondly
looking at the horizon of iot there are
a lot more
degrees of freedom in terms of the ways
we can interact with these
new devices so with that i want to go to
acknowledgements acknowledge the
collaborators and students and also the
funding agencies thank you